el plan parecía perfecto unos días de
relax en la isla tropical de jaén a
conocida como la hawai china disfrutando
de sus playas paradisíacas y de sus
compras libres de impuestos hasta ahí
llegaron masas de turistas muchos de
ellos desde shanghai para recuperarse de
un traumático confinamiento de más de
dos meses pero todo empezó a torcerse a
principios de agosto la isla que solo
había registrado un par de casos
asintomáticos hasta entonces ahora ya
suman más de 2500 casos y las
autoridades alertan de que el brote está
en expansión unos 178 mil turistas han
quedado atrapados y solo en los dos
últimos días han empezado a salir en
cuentagotas y tras haber encadenado
cinco resultados negativos muchos
turistas sin embargo siguen encerrados
en sus hoteles jaén han concentra la
mayoría de casos pero los brotes no
escasean en todo el país es el caso del
tíbet que sólo ha contado con un caso
asintomático hasta ahora y que el martes
se registró una treintena las medidas
urgentes se incluyen la construcción de
tres hospitales y el confinamiento de
buena parte la capital lhasa donde se ha
cerrado también el palacio potala la
célebre residencia interna de los lamas
y que es su principal atracción
turística